[Music]
thank you
good boy
I want that fighter strip for parts by
tomorrow
let's go get paid
that worked
because he knows how to handle the
Empire we cannot trust those officers
they take our credits now but let's stop
them from stabbing Us in the back
next
hit that button
[Music]
nice one
hang on tight little buddy
I was just leaving
okay okay we'll figure this out
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Nick
this is getting bad
let's try this out
stink ferric
[Music]
foreign
I think that went pretty well right
[Music]
all right
that was close
I got the package where are you waiting
for you
were you seen I said I got it what else
matters
anytime soon
um well they'll probably forgive me
[Music]
there's jonta's hope we made it next
hey Andy
your late cake Doc is waiting what are
you worried no
okay
put your Troy what
be careful
donkey's a broker not a friend
she can't be trusted who can out here
see you back at the ship
round two and I still like my odds
okay vess back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
who's a friend
join us
job was more complicated than you said
Danka
lived
hey these aren't toys
their Investments
foreign
wait
and met
I don't really know many of you
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart
[Music]
thanks but I'm smart enough to get
myself out of trouble you pay the tax
just like everyone else whoa kid let's
just relax
[Music]
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
old Troopers we have reports of a
fugitive in Georgia's hope move to
apprehend
Italian
could be I told you not to trust her
not the first time we've ever on the
empire
we need to leave yeah no kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
are we good nothing on the sensors yet
anybody on the sensors
on us
I feel inclined to remind you that we
should shake the Empire quickly thanks
I'm working on it
[Music]
let's jump
we made it
[Music]
hey
got your new toy
[Music]
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
all right
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024.
[Music]